[Musique]
malgré les apparences voler dans les
antilles et y faire fonctionner une
compagnie aérienne n'est pas si simple
que ça il ya d'abord les obligations
administratives les règlements photo
jurant tard de 10 ans ou 15 ans les
progrès techniques
l'administration a tellement compliqué
les choses et tellement
surveillez tellement ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on n'a plus la liberté qu'on
avant avant pour monter dans l'avion on
appelle à tous on osait le plan de vol
comme sap radio on disait je vais à tel
endroit je tends d'autonomie thème
passagers va là on perd plus de temps en
papier que en heure de vol je veux dire
quand je vois partir sur saint barth où
ces dix minutes de vol j'ai passé une
heure faut que j'arrive une heure avant
à l'aéroport autre petit souci la
mécanique car bien souvent les pièces de
rechange ne sont pas disponibles et il
faut les faire venir des états unis mais
les avions aujourd'hui tombent rarement
en panne
s'ils sont bien entretenus les faits
après il faut bien tenir compte de la
météo mais d'autres phénomènes naturels
peuvent aussi perturbé la navigation
aérienne
montserrat en 1995 le volcan soufrière
hills entre en éruption et la lave
recouvre une grande partie de l'île
l'aérodrome comme la capitale plymouth
disparaîtront sous la lave et
aujourd'hui encore les nuages de cendres
perturbe le trafic aérien
[Musique]
recueillant l'auteur peintre est parti
aux lilas
une des priorités des habitants a été de
construire un nouvel aéroport au nord de
l'île piloter un avion aux antilles
n'est pas toujours facile même si cela
reste un rêve un rêve qui peut réserver
quelques surprises
dans les caraïbes il n'est pas rare
d'apercevoir des cils fantôme
les îles chantôme ça existe welmant moi
ça m'est arrivé une fois entre dominique
et martine
j'ai vu une phantom à ma gauche à
l'ouest
d'ailleurs quand vous voyez une île
quelque part que vous savez quand ça
n'existe pas alors c'est que ces
fantômes
c'est tout simplement l'ombre portée et
nuages sur la mer ça n'arrive pas quand
on connaît bien le coin parce que c'est
pas qu'on ait pour un pilote qui chien
chez lui la face il la voit brusquement
sur le côté il pense que ses livres
[Musique]